you know what i like more than anything
else
no
don't think of something cheeky
some good old-fashioned cringe are you
ready
i know how much you love it i'm cringing
already uh i can't even watch the office
because the cringe i want to be married
and have a hundred kids so i can have a
hundred friends and no one can say no to
being my friend
why
i don't know two episodes that aren't
true i got cringed and like i don't want
to stop
guy quits his 100k job to work for logan
paul i gotta say i think logan paul
handled this whole thing pretty well i
don't know you saw this uh okay
i just talked to logan paul
hello they're crying too how's this dude
he's like 20 years old how do you have a
100k job do you work with like bad or
something yeah i don't know why they're
just making them see that i don't
believe i mean like he was just being
nice and i get it media whatever he has
to be nice
before i approached him yes
making three million dollars
i make a hundred thousand dollars here
22 i do make a hundred thousand that's
cool and i wanna
i wanna act i wanna i wanna do these
things you're not bro you're not making
any sense if you wanna act you don't go
to logan paul my dude you're influencing
me he's acting
[Music]
what better time to have a breakdown
than on your tick tock if you make a
decision like that that will make you
have a breakdown and if the answer is no
and it's not a good choice to make
before we continue quick word from
sponsor as you guys can see i'm now in
japan
[Music]
[Applause]
as you now can see i am in sweden
how do i do that that's crazy no baby
with a vpn you can access the internet
from anywhere super fast super reliable
and super duper safe that's right other
people can be spying on you unless
you're using a vpn especially
not just at home but especially if
you're using a public wi-fi they know
bro
don't let them know bro noor vpn has now
upped their level of security as well
with the new feature called threat
protection none of the other ones has
this by the way okay only vpn exclusive
it's a great tool that steps up your
cyber security it protects you from
malicious websites uh malicious
downloads trackers intrusive ads and
this is constantly on the lookout just
turn it on and that's it you don't even
have to connect to a vpn necessarily to
use this feature i highly recommend it
to say make sure you protect yourself
and stay safe the price is very low with
only 586 yen a month what what even is
that
but most importantly you save 69
you're gonna take that deal aren't you
if you go for the two-year plan you get
a huge discount plus one additional
month for free it's risk-free with
nordvpn's 30-day money-back guarantee
try it out and this is only available if
you use my link in the description so
make sure you use that that's it on with
the video you know there's millions
people trying to do what i'm trying to
do
let's watch the clip okay
just watch the clip no i no i didn't i
quit my job no wait
it's a story i'm interested i'm a story
i quit my job legit two days ago i came
up here took a risk i'm originally from
ohio
sneak up here no i didn't sneak in here
i didn't think what do you mean like on
stage are you just like yes i did you're
one of it's one of the sneaky sneakers i
just did you print the ticket and stuff
no i just need to talk to you i really
i'm trying to talk to your brother i'm
trying to talk about business trying to
talk about trying to get a job
like i want to i want to do a video that
face he made already said like no like
no one's gonna just like wow
wow you interfered with like my personal
space yes let me give you more of you in
here like no those are the people you
want to stay away from
you think the whole like oh people that
are persistent they're successful so i
should give this no that's [ __ ] i
did that video you know like oh
i'm 22 years old i'm just trying i can't
be a mentor i love that he put
everything on the line to just looking
for a job and he gets the most simple
question that he can't answer why would
i hire you i'm 22.
that's his answer i need a mentor please
please senpai
[Laughter]
i'm here by myself
this guy in the background is freaking
cracking up you have friends bro you're
[ __ ] lying you have friends
go make content do stuff with your
friends i'm glad you quit your job it
takes balls to do that bro but like now
you got to actually try to make a step
i'm not idea but i'm not the guy
directly
you're the guy you're the guy bro my
team is
this
i'm not the guy like you know life isn't
about yeah what people think they have
this huge team zone whatever like
another one just said maybe some people
do i don't know you got like 500 people
working for you right
no
i have two people right because i have
two youtube channels and they edit
videos for me they go
yeah i know i'm not trying to hand out
i'm not trying to get are you trying to
do them i'm trying to work hard for a
little money no money i don't know i can
get a job
he's watched too many videos of that guy
we made fun of which i forgot the name
on the
uh do the advice dude yeah the guy that
kisses his dad on the lips
9700 things they can think of that their
parents [ __ ] up and they still love
them
on this episode i have my dad join me oh
oh
jeez
nope pull that up
just quit your job what's your job today
yeah stop saying wrong nice 10 million
people watching the show about smart
people every night celebrating being
smart and i thought you know what maybe
it's not so bad being smart maybe it's
not bad being a nerd maybe it's cool to
be smart and i followed that all the way
and i just graduated from medical school
that's awesome congratulations
this is what you're up against fourteen
questions from five hundred dollars wait
he gets it first question of course
you're gonna have two lifelines to use
you know we can only laugh if we get
this question right right if we get it
wrong yeah yeah
here's your 500 question
i'm under easy present okay so having
stuff in the kitchen you can't afford
and taking a meatball break are two
things buzzfeed says every 20 something
does on their first trip where
what oh ikea
sweden
no
yeah i care
i i would be banished from sweden if i
got this one wrong i think
to paris oh my god the options
to ikea
i'll tell you what i think they do serve
meatballs in ikea so he knows uh
i don't think that's the right answer
though so kitchens you can't afford
no no sounds like it's gotta be wrong
for me in fact if i was a million
dollars i would love to take a trip to
italy i'm going to say rome final answer
[Music]
oh brittany was ikea
yes
yes
oh he even took the time to talk through
all of his oh you know
[Applause]
you know what they do have meatballs in
italy and they're not that good
oh
you better watch your back march is
going to hear you say that this was an
easy question he may be book smart for
you got no comments that she they didn't
teach you that in med school
they don't teach you about meatballs
there you stick
into an ikea shoot and where else would
you go and like get a kitchen that you
can't afford or whatever
you know when you watch videos of people
professionals failing at something like
even though they do you can never do
you're still like what an idiot
amateur yeah
so the couch eating chips amateur yeah
that's what i do when i'm watching the
olympics oh it's your favorite
strawberry ice cream strawberry ice
cream
boo worst ice cream thickness finally
sinks their water to an unimpressed
dairy queen input
[Music]
ice
[Music]
oh god i'm like bro i'm paid three
dollars an hour can you just like not
what did you want again i didn't get you
this brings back memories for me as well
because we used to have i think i
totally we used to have a ringtone in
our family where we would sing a song it
was a jingle like
you have called yeah you have called to
the shelbert family now we're not
homeless
took a ring another time again that's a
translation roughly
me me and my sister we loved it we
thought it was so funny like we had the
coolest ringtone everyone else
i remember telling other parents about
it like have you heard a ringtone by the
way and they're like
yeah
yeah
every time i call you
it was until years later it clicked to
me like everyone just thought it was
[ __ ] annoying
i didn't realize you you hate cringe so
much it's kind of funny you're just
hearing you make noises from pain every
day i'm the i'm the worst youtuber ever
like i legitimately get scared at horror
games so i don't want to play him
i actually cringe at cringe the point
right i don't want to watch him i don't
know what i can do now i just
what's [ __ ] good
i'm easing you into it
you want to enjoy this stuff you want to
save it show me more i can't wait to
watch more please
everyone out there with their fake
reactions i got the real reactions right
here i hate it i hate it
a forced product placement cutscene in
this is the kind of games you play again
me i don't play this game
i see you popping up on steam and what
the [ __ ] is he playing now oh yeah you
see me i gotta get bug up in my ball
bruh
hey neighbor are you
jake from state farm oh you hang out
here bro yeah hey right next to the
course in your neighborhood hey that's
total family hey speaking of being a
good neighbor
here
very excited to have the great mp as my
newest neighbor hey look i appreciate
that man i didn't realize you were found
and remember like a good neighbor stay
farm is there i was waiting for you to
say it man hey look what the do you get
it i don't get it so the guy from state
farmers showed up in the game so that
you can think the state farm is cool
yeah pretty cringe
[Laughter]
damn it's just a commercial in the game
state farm seems pretty lit fam
yeah yeah
yeah flames
i love how product placement is like
totally fine in america and like it's so
weird like no this is not an avenue
we're just chilling we're just chilling
on my with my homie i was watching the
stranger things
and someone's like oh would you like a
coke and hand them a coconut like ah ah
product placement they're doing it
they're doing it
you know you know it's product placement
whenever they have like they pull out
bing in the browser
oh we need to look up online let me just
check out bing let me check out bingo
they have a story about like people
having superpowers and like special
abilities like that's fine
bing
i'm totally taken out of the immersion
no this is not really real nobody uses
being nobody
that's like look at the second page of a
google search oh my god
[Music]
saxophone's silent all right
[Music]
oh no
i even looked at him like bruh
[Music]
it sounds like those mean flutes
[Music]
could this be like his reef is broken or
something like that
he wouldn't be able to if it was broke
it wouldn't even play like this dude
drunk or something oh my god
he's not even playing anything difficult
he's just
i feel like i could pick up a saxophone
phone and play better than that i never
hold the saxophone no you're in the way
of cancer you stop back
yes
[Music]
they are brutal man they have no chill
not everyone obviously but yeah my
experience same thing you need a dude
like this on the phone that just like
steps in the way all the time
no you can't take pictures yes he knows
what he's doing i don't think i ever saw
this one but i know it was cringe this
is the one where they try and make it
like world of warcraft
yes it is
[Applause]
bro just drink a coat
oh yeah
the quality of this is insane they how
much money did they put into this
hopefully not as much as pepsi put into
a freakin
[Laughter]
riot
it's crazy oh man
these giants still get it so wrong man
i drank the coke
oh my friends are dying
no longer fighting alan walker's there
you seen this ah
and was found with knowledge
lost with the ink
i'm so much worse than i thought he was
oh god oh
what what meeting do they have
to green like this like and then you
drink the coke
you know esports is like the next big
thing with kids you know that's a
competitive gaming but then coke just
brings them together and then everyone
completely wastes their time for the
event and we ruined the whole thing no
you should have made that work like
super buffed and like murder everyone
i'll be like yeah let me get some of
that code
it was stupid cringe but not as cringe
as that mom vlogger forces her kids to
cry on camera
oh
oh yeah you've seen this for her
to bring her home
and be part of her it already has ads on
it that's nice all right she's crying
and she needs her kid to cry too you
know
we appreciate it i love you guys
[Music]
act like you're crying
[Music]
oh
[Music]
look at me look at me
this is this is the stuff i can't watch
that's too much man he's one of the
reasons why i stopped doing like family
vlogs not because we were doing stuff
like this but because like
you're like industry yeah like it's like
a very slippery slope before like your
life becomes like the content and like
there's all these stories of like family
vloggers basically
they seem insane
yeah it's just like this horrible stuff
and not that we'd ever get to that point
but i just didn't even want like
anything to even do with that industry
you know i just wanted to like just
completely stay away from it and
you ever feel like we caused this
do we call it
i don't take any responsibility for that
all right no that's not what i mean but
it's like when we started everything is
so simple and that's simpler it's
corrosion into such a monster sometimes
you're like what the [ __ ] maybe
maybe he's better without it bro con
player walks into gamestop and expected
to get noticed
you know this dude
nope i can't tell you they got their way
you don't recognize him right away
they get the face clan they got the f on
their backpack thing so maybe he should
he should walk around with a sign that
says his kd
okay over there
god there's nothing more cringe than
like
a a content creator going anywhere and
being like don't you know who i am you
know there's nothing more crazy
[Music]
at a convention one time i saw a fellow
content creator i'm not going to any
names uh get heated there's a line to
like waiting to get into something and
they're like don't you know who i am and
i like literally almost died from cringe
on the spot i was like no
no why do you have to be in this way
someone actually said it
outside of your bubble no one does know
who you are
that face wrong
oh his face drug yeah yeah he's in the
room i remember when i uh was like just
barely started and then they wanted to
write an article on me and i was super
hyped for it and they're like wouldn't
it be cool if we go outside would you
get recognized if that happens i was
like i guess it happened like a couple
times they're like can we go outside and
see if like if anyone recognizes you and
i'm like
no
that's weird no i do that no no please i
love you just walked into game stuff
like that yeah
youtube
[Music]
he plays call of duty he plays call of
duty wow
i feel like i made you endure enough
cringe for the everyone
with me
sorry but it's over
you may never
never recover from this if today's your
birthday happy birthday smash like
subscribe for more videos check out ken
thanks
every like to heal ken from one cringe
oh good
please no more